BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Welcome,
and thanks for joining us.
Today we're going to be
talking about how Google Cloud
Observability suite of products
is creating a better developer
experience for its customers.
I'm Bryan Zimmerman, product
manager with Google Cloud.
MEREDITH HASSETT: And I'm
Meredith Hassett, developer
advocate at Corvid by Wix.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: As
I mentioned, we're
going to be talking
about specific tools
that help developers be
more successful day to day.
But these exist within
a larger ecosystem.
And this toolset is based off
the same planet scale core
platform that powers Google's
internal observability.
So you know it's
been battle-tested.
In addition, it comes with
built-in zero day observability
for key Google services.
This is all under the umbrella
of our logging and monitoring
products, but it
includes much more.
When talking about how to
help developers day to day,
we first have to ask,
what do developers
needs from their
observability toolset?
When we talk to our
customers, there
are three key
themes that we see.
First, they need to
diagnose issues quickly.
When there's an issue with
your application or site,
there isn't time to go
hunting for logs or hunting
for metrics.
You need to be able
to find the problem
and diagnose the
problem with ease.
Second, some problems are
harder to find than others.
And with a large data available
about your application
and the infrastructure it runs
on-- especially in the cloud--
having a toolset that
helps you effectively
find needles in that
haystack is really important.
Thirdly, not all issues
can be reproduced
in a development environment.
And even if they can
be, it's time consuming
and sometimes you
need answers quickly.
So being able to
debug in production
is often critical to reducing
mean time to resolution
and being effective
in the cloud.
We're going to be talking
about each of these areas,
with specific examples of
how they can help developers
be more effective.
First of all, let's talk about
diagnosing issues quickly.
Metrics are a key part
to understanding problems
and what's happening
with your system.
Traces in logs have
the context and details
to help you diagnose the
cause of said issues,
but they're not always
linked together.
So going from a metric to
the request and logs that
generated that particular
metric data point
is difficult and important
to be able to diagnose issues
quickly.
What's the solution?
A feature we call "example
traces," otherwise known
as trace exemplars.
In the screenshot
on the left, you
can see a heat map
distribution of latency.
That has two
important additions--
one, there are aggregate
percentile lines
that help us understand how
this distribution is trending.
Second, there are example
distributed traces
that have been sampled.
These represent
complete requests
and you can actually
drill into that request
without leaving the context
of your monitoring tool, which
you'll see in a moment.
Now let's see this in action.
The demo we're about to show you
is of our example application
called Online Boutique.
In this scenario, users
of the application,
who normally experience
great performance,
have started to notice
extremely degraded latency.
The developer in the
video will show you
how to use the Google
Cloud operations Tool
Suite and example traces,
as I mentioned earlier,
to quickly diagnose said issue.
Here we will show how we can
use Cloud Monitoring and Cloud
Trace to quickly
understand where
we should be focusing our
attention with regards
to a particular issue.
In this case, we
have an alert related
to 99th percentile
latency, which has spiked
quite significantly recently.
Drilling into our
performance dashboard,
we can see that there was a
significant increase in latency
around the time of the alert.
This seems to possibly
correlate with error rate,
but not exactly.
This increase can be shown
both by the distribution
itself, but also the
aggregate percentile lines
and how they have
increased over time.
Let's drill in further
to the inflection point.
Now, typically, this is
actually quite difficult
to go from here.
Understanding the
specific requests
that led to that
metric data point
is not always easily available.
However, with Google
Cloud Operations,
we can overlay example traces
onto this metrics graph.
Now we can easily,
without switching context,
drill into exactly
what was happening
at the time the
issue was observed.
So in this instance,
this is a call
to the product service, which
is making a call to get product,
and making further calls
to get product, which
is an interesting behavior.
Out of the 7 seconds
duration, about 6.9 of them
were related to get product.
Let's see if this
seems to correlate
with other types of requests.
This is another similar
such product call,
which has a similar
profile of child calls
to the product catalog service.
This here is a cart operation,
so that's different.
However, when we
look further, it
has this same get repeated get
product call in the product
catalog service
that we saw earlier.
And if we look
further, we're going
to see similar behavior
of product catalog service
operations representing the
majority of the latency.
Now, to be sure of this,
let's compare with traces
prior to the issue.
Here's a similar
get product call.
And it's making calls to the
recommendation service, again,
to the get product service.
And it makes a few
calls to get product,
which is what we saw before.
However, if you look
at the total latency,
only 31 milliseconds were spent
within the get product service.
This compares to 20 seconds in
some of the other examples we
were investigating.
So it definitely seems to be
a delta in the length of time
of get product calls that is
representative of this latency.
At this point, I have
a viable hypothesis
for what caused this issue.
And I got there without
actually leaving
my monitoring dashboard.
From here, I would look at
logging, perhaps debugging,
error reporting, to try and
understand what was actually
causing this issue.
But what we've shown here is
that with these integrated
tools, you can quickly
understand where you should
be focusing your
attention and where
the problem may be located.
The previous example
focused on speed.
But that's not
always what you need.
When it comes to finding
needles in the haystack,
it's about breadth, depth, and
thoroughness of your tool set.
In the next example,
we're going to show
how you can use the Google
Cloud Operations Tool
Suite to look for a very
difficult-to-find cause
of an issue.
This focus is on
logging and trace.
And we'll follow that
up with profiler.
To demonstrate finding
a needle in a haystack,
we're going to look through
Cloud Monitoring, Cloud Trace,
and Cloud Logging.
Starting with Cloud
Monitoring, we
see that we have an
alert related to latency.
Looking at our dashboards,
in specific, the performance
dashboard, we see
that there actually
was a spike in the errors
on the front end that
occurred fairly recently.
To troubleshoot
this, we're going
to drill into things
with Cloud Logging.
Looking in the logs
viewer, I can very easily
filter for the log lines
that contain error.
I can also drill down to
the Kubernetes resource type
where the errors came from.
In this case, they're almost
all from the front end.
So what's happening
in these instances?
Drilling into the
details for these
logs, I can see
what's happening.
In this case, I see fail
to get recommendations.
I expect that other
errors are very similar.
Failed to get product
recommendations again.
I can add this to
the summary line
in order to see how prevalent
this error is within my filter
criteria.
Now, to understand what the
recommendation service is
doing, let's open Cloud Trace.
And in this case, I'm
going to filter for spans--
otherwise known
as service calls--
where my front end is calling
my recommendation service.
We can see that the latency
spiked heavily around the time
that I received the alert and
started receiving those errors.
Let's see what's happening.
What we can see here is after
calling list recommendations,
the system is making
multiple calls
to get product from the
product catalog service.
That's interesting.
In fact, in this
19 second trace,
which started as a
get cart request,
almost all of the latency
is spent within those
get product calls.
That's definitely not
what we want to see.
And it suggests that that's
where the issue is occurring.
We're going to use Cloud
Logging to understand
what's happening within that
product catalog service.
Again, it's very
easy to find this out
by drilling in to the resource
type in the field explorer.
We're going to filter for
the pod named product catalog
service.
Now, what we can see is roughly
at the time of the error,
there is a massive spike
in logs from this service.
Narrowing down to
this time interval,
we can see that almost
all of these logs
are a successfully
parsed product catalog.
At this point, it's safe to
assume that this is where
I should focus my attention.
I'm going to open up my
IDE and understand what's
happening with the parsing
of the product catalog
to find out why is it
actually successfully parsing
the product catalog so often.
This is a good example of
how to use the operations
toolset, including
logging, trace, monitoring,
and more to quickly narrow
down a hard-to-find problem.
Sometimes a problem
can't be easily found
in the logs or the traces.
It has to do more
with the functioning
of your running code, or perhaps
it's about cost optimization.
This is where a profiler
is extremely useful.
Kellyanne is going to show
you how you can use Profile
to solve these
needle-in-the-haystack type
problems.
KELLYANNE: Log Profiler can
help developers understand
how their services are spending
compute and memory resources.
We will explore
how Profiler can be
used to identify
optimization opportunities
and help you run your
services more efficiently.
Profiler supports
four languages--
Java, Go, NodeJS, and Python.
For this walk through, we will
use the product catalog service
and its CPU time profile tag.
The default view for provider
is the flame graph view
shown here.
It helps developers understand
which portions of their code
are using the most resources.
In this service, we can see
that the stack with the function
parse catalog is using
the most CPU time--
about 72%.
We can see the parse catalog is
calling the JSON and Marshall
function.
So this has to be the first
focus of our investigation.
Now, let's open the
top Functions table
and sort the Functions
list by the Serve Time.
We can see that 8.3% of CPU time
is spent in the function state
in string, which is not evident
from the default view shown
in the flame graph.
By clicking on
this function name,
we load the flame graph
in the focus filter mode.
This more is useful
to identify functions,
which are called from multiple
locations in your code.
It also helps us understand
the various calling paths
into this function.
This is very useful for
understanding the resource
usage patterns of
library functions, which
may be called from different
locations in your code.
Removing the focus filter
resets the flame graph
to its default view.
Now let's examine how we
can use the wait filter
to identify profiles
within a selected
percentage of peak consumption.
For example, top 10% indicates
that only profiles that
were collected during the
top 10% of CPU consumption
are presented for analysis.
We can also use the compare to
function to compare profiles
from two different wait groups.
Here we are comparing
profiles from the top 10%
with all profiles.
The frames that are
shaded in orange
have higher resource
consumption when
compared with all profiles.
We can see that there is
some increase in resource
consumption in the client
handshake function stack,
as well.
Resetting the compared to loads
the default flame graph view.
So these are some of
the features of Profiler
that can be used by
developers to understand
how their services
are spending resources
and where they should start
their optimization efforts.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN: Our
final scenario talks
about how to debug
code when it counts.
If you've ever had a
scenario where you could not
reproduce an issue in your
development environment,
then this is for you.
If you've ever had a scenario
where that one line of logging
that you needed was not
there when you needed it,
this is for you.
In this next demo,
we're going to see
how Cloud Debugger can help
you debug in production
when you need it most.
To start this journey, we're
going to open error reporting.
Error reporting
automatically surfaces
errors found in the logs
for easy discoverability.
Within the error group,
we can see the trend
where this error has
occurred, where in the code
this error has
occurred, and easily
link to the logs that
generated the error.
Exploring these logs,
we can see quite easily.
But this is exclusively caused
by the currency service.
We can inspect the logs
for further details,
including resource context.
However, this doesn't
actually show us
what's happening and causing
this particular problem.
For that, we're going
to open Cloud Debugger.
Debugger allows
us to see what is
happening in our actual
running production code.
In the logs, you
saw that the error
was happening at line 55 of
the currency service server JS.
Clicking here, we
can take a snapshot
of what's happening at the
code at that exact position,
inspecting the details
of the variables.
This was done without
restarting the service,
without pausing the service,
completely safe in production.
Now, the cause
isn't obvious here,
but we can see from the
code that if results
dot units is not
greater than zero,
it would throw this error.
So let's see what results
dot units is set at.
In this case, it's
set at not a number.
So that's obviously
not going to work.
Let's see how this
was actually set.
And in this case,
where we set that value
was also not a valid number.
As such, it will
generate the error
that you saw today in the logs.
Next, we would need to update
the code to resolve this issue.
But you can see how with
production debugging
this was easy to find without
any impact to my system.
And that concludes
our three scenarios.
Next we're going to hear from
Meredith Hassett from Wix.
MEREDITH HASSETT: Thanks, Bryan.
At Corvid by Wix, we're all
about developer velocity.
And using tools like Google
Cloud Operations really
helps developers speed
up their process.
Corvid enables a JavaScript
web development environment
on top of Wix sites,
which enables developers
to add additional
console logging,
as well as error
handling, that's
crucial for their
logging experience.
By integrating Google Cloud
operations into Corvid,
developers are able
to rapidly debug
issues that come
up in production
and make sure their users are
getting the best experience.
Let's take a look at how a
real live Corvid developer uses
Corvid and Google Cloud
Operations to build and debug
issues on their site.
Let's take a look at a
vacation booking site,
where users can provide their
preferred check in and check
out dates to get updated
quote information
about their requested holiday.
We're able to do this
using Corvid and Wix to get
dynamic information from
third parties displayed
on our screen.
Let's take a look at how
this looks in the code.
In our Wix editor, we now see a
new site structure and code IDE
pane.
So that becomes available
once we enable Corvid.
Corvid is our web development
platform for Wix sites
that opens up APIs as
well as UI functionality
for you as a developer.
When we finally
request quote function,
we can see it's actually
coming from the back end
and the logify file.
So if we go ahead
and take a look
at our logify file
in our backend,
we're able to find the
request quote function
and see that it's
calling an API to return
booking information about
a property based off
the user's inputs.
Once that quote's
returned, we may actually
want to do some error handling
to determine if there's
any issues with the quote.
So let's go ahead and
log quote information
and then check to see if the
quote has any error codes.
If there is an
error code, we may
want to return an error status
to be able to better debug.
We're able to pass through
properties from the quote,
as well, to the error.
Once our error
handling and logging
is in place, if we
publish, this would make
our site changes productive.
With our production site up
and ready to go, let's go ahead
and enable the logging back
on our Wix site dashboard.
When we go to Settings,
Production Tools, Site
Monitoring, we're able to easily
connect to the Google Cloud
Operations Logging Tools.
When we connect, we just connect
with our Google single sign
on account.
And we're able to
get to the Dashboard.
Once we're in the
Google Cloud Dashboard,
we're able to look at
the logs for our site.
So let's take a look at what
a user's flow may look like
and how we can do
some error handling.
Back in my Wix Editor, I'm
going to go to View Site.
And on my site I'm going to go
through a user flow of trying
to book a vacation.
Let's take a look at the
properties that are available
and select one that looks
like a nice vacation home.
Once I'm on the Vacation
Properties page,
I'm able to play around
with the quote information
and see how changing
my requested dates
will change my
quote information.
We can go through trying
to book this site, as well.
Now we'll try to
place my booking.
As a user, if I run
into any issues,
I can process information
back along to the agency
and see if they can help me
figure out what's going on.
As a developer, to make sure
that your site is healthy,
if we take a look
back at our logs,
we're able to retrieve if
there is any information
and find any errors.
I can filter down
for my errors, see
that there is an issue
with a quote retrieval,
and determine what
went wrong by taking
a look at the information
and the other events logged
around it.
Having integrated tools
like Google Cloud Operations
for logging of websites like
those built on Corvid by Wix
enables us as developers to
do our jobs more efficiently,
spend less time
looking for errors,
and be able to resolve any
issues that our users may
be having when they're
coming to our sites.
BRYAN ZIMMERMAN:
Thanks, Meredith.
And there you have it.
We've demonstrated how
Google Cloud Operation
suite of products can
help make developers
more effective and
efficient day to day.
Feel free to reach out
for more information,
or as always, visit us
at cloud.google.com.